Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 111 von UKW.
Und wie sollte es anders sein? Auch heute liegt der Fokus wieder auf der Ukraine,
ist einiges passiert seit unserer letzten Sendung und ihr merkt schon,
insgesamt geht es ein wenig ab.
So Dinge passieren wieder, nachdem der Krieg lange lange Zeit so in einem gleichbleibenden
hin und her hat er, hält das ganze Geschehen jetzt eine neue Dynamik und die
wollen wir natürlich jetzt hier berichten.
Wir sind natürlich meine Wenigkeit und natürlich Pawel. Hallo Pawel.
Hallo Tim.
Letzte Sendung war vom 17. Mai 23,
da haben wir sie veröffentlicht und ja das war kurz nach den Angriffen,
Drohnenangriffen auf russischem Gebiet vor allem des Kremls,
das war so ein bisschen das was die Zeit geprägt hat und natürlich die Eroberung Bachmuths.
Ich glaube, wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt wenige Tage, es waren dann nur noch
wenige Tage, bis dann auch noch so die letzten paar Häuser niedergewalzt wurden in Bachmuth.
Von der Stadt ist halt jetzt herzlich wenig übrig und die Russen konnten ja
in Anführungsstrichen da einen Sieg feiern,
der halt eigentlich nicht wirklich ein Sieg war,
sondern halt mehr so eine Einnahme eines tiefgeliegenen Stadtgebiets,
was rein militärstrategisch überhaupt gar
keinen nennenswerten wert hat sondern
nur so eine propagandanummer der russen
letzten endes war mit viel verlusten auf beiden seiten und je nachdem wie man
mehr glauben schenken möchte lief das sehr asymmetrisch ab ich denke ukraine
hat sich dazu entschieden Wachmut zu erhalten, um Zeit zu gewinnen.
Weil die Gegend ja relativ leicht zu verteidigen war durch diese vielen Häuser,
das heißt der Aufwand den die Russen dort betreiben mussten war sehr sehr sehr
hoch und die Verluste waren dementsprechend sehr hoch, auch wenn man natürlich
im Krieg keinen Zahlen wirklich glauben darf, die beide Seiten so veröffentlichen.
Kann man glaube ich schon sagen, das war auf jeden Fall für Russland sehr kostlich,
sicherlich auch für die Ukraine, aber unterm Strich war die Entscheidung halt die,
Das ist für uns die beste Möglichkeit die Angriffsmöglichkeiten der Russen auf
einen Ort zu konzentrieren und dort zu verteidigen und zu verhindern,
dass Kämpfe in anderen Bereichen ausbrechen, weil die Russen einfach so fokussiert
waren, durch ihre eigene Propaganda auch auf diesen Ort.
Und hat einfach Zeit gegeben, weitere Kräfte im Hinterland auszubilden,
neue Technik ins Land zu bringen, neue Brigaden aufzustellen, etc.
Um die nun schon seit Ewigkeiten angekündigte Gegenoffensive dann irgendwann einmal einzuleiten.
Und jetzt sind halt die Fronten in Bachmuth ein wenig eingefroren,
was vor allem auch daran liegt, dass halt die Wagner-Truppen jetzt ihren Job
erstmal als erledigt angesehen haben und sich zurückgezogen haben.
Zu Bachmuth kommen wir dann auch gleich nochmal, aber das war jetzt so sagen
wir mal so ein bisschen der Zeitpunkt zu dem wir die letzte Sendung beendet haben.
Ja und dann ist doch so einiges passiert und es sind einige sehr überraschende Sachen passiert.
Und angefangen hat es mit einer Attacke auf russischem Gebiet und das ist natürlich
insofern ein Novum als das ja eigentlich die Ukraine bisher die eigene Grenze
so nie überschritten hat.
Also wissen wir natürlich nicht und sicherlich gab es hier und da mal ein paar
Meter Grenzübertritt und so Angriffe auf lokale Infrastruktur gab es ja ohnehin mit Drohnen.
Nicht wahr, dass da immer mal wieder irgendwelche Funkmasten, Öllager etc.
Angegriffen wurden, teilweise ja auch weit ins russische Hinterland hinein,
aber dass jetzt eben wirklich Truppen die Grenze überschreiten und dort auf
russischem Staatsgebiet Kämpfe durchführen mit Infanterie,
Das ist insofern etwas komplett Neues und was halt besonders neu daran ist,
dass es die Ukraine in dem Sinne so auch nicht war,
Klammer auf, doch eigentlich schon, Klammer zu, aber in der offiziellen Darstellung
haben sie halt gesagt, das sind ja gar nicht wir, das sind ja alles Russen.
Und dann wurden dann vor allem so zwei...
Gruppen genannt, ja also die russische Volksfront und die Volksfront von Russland.
Wie hießen die Gruppen? Irgendwas mit Freiheit, Russland, hast du es drauf?
Ich habe es mir nicht genau gemerkt, wie die beiden Gruppen sich nennen.
Die eine ganz klar rechtsauslegermäßig und die andere eher anders?
Das eine ist halt die russische Legion. Also da gibt es ja diverse,
irgendwie gibt es ja noch die weißrussische Legion und generell sowas wie die Fremdenlegion,
wo dann halt, ja, Russen im Wesentlichen kämpfen auf Seiten der Ukrainer und
von denen eben auch ausgerüstet und bewaffnet werden.
Insofern, ja, ist es, ich sag mal, ein netter PR-Gag so und eigentlich auch
eine Retourkutsche an Russland und seine Little Green Men damals,
die dann 2014 halt überall in der Ukraine aufgetaucht, also der Krim, sind.
Genau bei der ersten Krim-Invasion.
Und ja, Invasionen im 2014 sind halt
jede Menge russische Truppen eingesickert ohne Hochheitsabzeichen und
da wurde das Ganze eben auch von den Russen
als quasi spontaner Volksaufstand versucht zu verkaufen und im Grunde genommen
machen die Ukrainer da jetzt gerade nicht viel anderes so und schicken nur dass der Unterschied war,
dass es damals sogar echte Russen waren und nicht irgendwelche russischsprachigen
Ukrainer oder nicht nur so oder russischstämmigen Ukrainer,
die da mobilisiert wurden, sondern ja,
da wurden dann damals auch Söldner und einfach Truppen ohne Hoheitsabzeichen
einfach in die in die Ukraine geschickt und dann so getan, als hätte man nichts damit zu tun.
Und ja, so ein bisschen ähnlich ist es halt jetzt nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass das jetzt halt als Reaktion auf einen Angriffskrieg erfolgt und somit auch legitim ist,
während das damals von Russland einfach eine Operation gegen die Ukraine war, eine unprovozierte.
Genau und was ist jetzt passiert? Also wir reden ja jetzt von einer Gegend im
Norden der gesamten Kriegshandlungen.
Also konkret dreht sich das eben ab in dem Oblast Belgorod.
In Russland ist es ja ähnlich wie in der Ukraine so, man hat halt immer diesen Oblast,
also vergleichbar zu so einem Bundesland bei uns und in der Regel heißen diese
Oblaste so wie die größte wichtigste Stadt dort, quasi wie die Hauptstadt selber.
Also Oblast Belgorod ist also das ganze Gebiet und die Stadt Belgorod ist da
eben das Zentrum und Belgorod ist natürlich auch ein ganz wichtiger Militärhub
für die Russen bei dieser Invasion.
Der Ukrainer und ist auch ganz gut unter Beschuss gekommen. Wir hatten in der
letzten Sendung auch, dass irgendwie die Russen das auch selber beschießen,
weil sie irgendwie ihr Friendly Fire nicht im Griff haben etc.
Das ganze ist also quasi nördlich von Rakiv,
also der Stadt Rakiv oder natürlich dann eben auch das Oblast Rakiv und Ja und
dann ein bisschen weiter im Westen sind dann eben diese russischen,
wie auch immer man sie nennen soll, Kämpfergruppen mit jetzt nicht so dem allermodernsten
Equipment aber teilweise schon so auch mit amerikanischen Humvees und so weiter.
Wo dann ja auch schon Journalisten so gefragt wurden, so ja wo habt ihr die
denn her? Ja die kann man auf dem freien Markt kaufen und so.
Das war wiederum so eine Replik, wie damals, als Putin dann gefragt wurde,
ja, wo haben denn diese Little Green Men ihre Waffen und Ausrüstung her?
Und da sagte Putin auch, ja, das kann man ja überall in Geschäften kaufen in der Ukraine.
Und das war dann sozusagen auch die Replik jetzt auf Putin, ja,
das kann man ja irgendwie in Läden überall kaufen in Russland.
So diese Waffen stehen da überall rum.
Also Thinly Veiled, natürlich steht die Ukraine dahinter, weil niemals würde
die Ukraine so eine Aktivität von ihrem eigenen Land aus genehmigen,
wenn ihnen das nicht voll in die Karten spielen würde.
Also ich glaube da kann man halt alle öffentlichen Wortäußerungen dazu eben
unter he he guter Witz abspeichern.
Natürlich steckt die Ukraine dahinter, aber sie hat eben diese russischen Korps
und wie sich später auch herausgestellt hat auch Polen, die dabei sind,
quasi dort vorgeschickt.
Die haben das Spiel mitgespielt und sind dann halt eben auch so öffentlich aufgetreten
mit ja wir befreien jetzt hier Russland und so. Ich meine davon kann natürlich
noch nicht die Rede sein, aber...
Erstmal war es bemerkenswert, sie konnten also relativ problemlos in das russische Hinterland eintreten,
es gab dort keinerlei nennenswerte Befestigung oder militärische Präsenz,
da waren halt nur so ein paar überraschte Konskripts sozusagen frisch eingezogene Russen,
die dann irgendwelche Polizeiposten da besetzt haben oder Grenzposten,
die natürlich in nullkomma nix überrumpelt wurden und nach hinten fliehen mussten,
wenn sie nicht sogar zu Schaden gekommen sind.
Und mir nichts, deren nichts konnten also mehrere Kilometer dort überbrückt
worden werden. Zunächst einmal
in den Ort Grai, also Richtung des Ortes Grai-Voron, Glotowo-Grai-Voron.
Da war dann erst mal Schluss und die Russen waren total ja auf dem linken Fuß
erwischt worden, haben dann irgendwie Truppenverstärkung dahin geschickt und,
nach ein, zwei Tagen haben sich dann aber auch diese Kämpfer wieder zurückgezogen.
So nach dem Motto war alles nur Spaß.
Denn das Ganze war halt im Prinzip ein Test auf der einen Seite,
so nach dem Motto, okay wie sieht es denn da jetzt aus? Aber was glaube ich
der eigentliche Hintergedanke war ist, damit haben die Russen natürlich irgendwie nicht mitgerechnet.
Hätten sie damit gerechnet, dann hätten sie natürlich dort ganz andere Verstärkungen,
aber sie schicken natürlich alle Kämpfer derzeit in die Ukraine,
Bachmuth und so weiter. und dass sich die Ukraine das überhaupt traut.
Glaube ich hatten die so nicht auf dem Zettel. Jetzt haben die das ja gemacht,
dazu eben noch mit diesem speziellen Spin mit höhö sind ja alles nur Russen
und das ist natürlich dann in der Öffentlichkeit auch wirklich schwer zu verkaufen.
Also erstmal die Ukraine greift Russland an auf dem eigenen Gebiet ist natürlich
schon mal so diese Unverletzlichkeit des eigenen Landes von dem sie immer soviel
reden und Was ja so der Grund war,
warum sie diesen ganzen Krieg überhaupt losgetreten haben,
also einer der vorgeschobenen Gründe war, warum sie diesen Krieg losgetreten
haben und auf einmal können die halt so mir nichts dir nichts einfach mal ein
paar Kilometer da ins Land einreiten und irgendwie Polizeistationen in Flammen
setzen und Leute erschießen und so weiter.
Nicht Zivilisten, sondern die haben sozusagen nur Militär oder polizeiliche Ziele dort gehabt,
aber Nichtsdestotrotz war das jetzt erstmal sehr schlechte PR für den Kreml
und der zweite Effekt ist natürlich,
und das würde ich sagen ist der Haupteffekt, jetzt können sie sich das natürlich
nicht weiter leisten, so da zu stehen, so angreifbar zu sein und müssen in irgendeiner
Form dort ihre militärische Präsenz erhöhen.
Aber wenn sie dort ihre militärische Präsenz erhöhen, heißt das,
dass sie wiederum einen weiteren Ort haben, wo sie Truppen konzentrieren müssen.
Und alle Truppen, die dort konzentriert werden, die können halt woanders nicht
konzentriert werden. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Strategie.
Dann war erstmal ein paar Tage wieder Ruhe, aber dann gab es gleich den nächsten
Angriff nach derselben Bauart.
Und der fand dann wiederum, also das war jetzt alles so im Südwesten von Belgorod
und dann ging dasselbe Spiel nochmal los im Südosten von Belgorod an einem anderen Grenzübergang.
Hier traf es dann halt die Stadt Shebekino, die ja also so ein,
weiß nicht, so was in der Größenordnung von 30.000,
Einwohnern oder sowas habe ich gehört, also schon auch
nicht ganz klein und dort gab es dann
gleich zwei Angriffe auf eine Grenzstation und
auf einen vorgelegenen kleineren Ort und
dort konnten halt auch diese russischen Kämpfer relativ weit vordringen und
dort ging es halt richtig zur Sache also da war dann richtig Alarm und die Russen
waren dann auch erstmal wieder genau so auf dem linken Fuß erwischt worden,
haben natürlich dann auch gegen gehalten unter anderem haben sie dann sozusagen
ihre eigenen Dörfer bombardiert so mit Artillerie und so weiter.
Aber es ging wohl auch Artillerie in die andere Richtung, unter anderem ist
da so ein großes administratives Gebäude getroffen worden in Chebikyn.
Also das war, sagen wir mal, schon eine nennenswerte kriegerische Auseinandersetzung,
was man allein schon Und daran sieht das halt ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung nach Begrot.
Also die Stadt Belgorod evakuiert werden musste.
Und es gab von angeblich russischer Seite sogar Berichte von einem angeblichen
russischen Wehrpflichtigen,
der da in den Kämpfen war,
dass 80 Prozent aus seiner Einheit getötet worden seien und dass ihnen der Rückzug
verboten worden sei und er beschuldigt da irgendwie den Obersten dran schuld zu sein,
dass die gesamte Einheit ausradiert wurde.
Ob das jetzt Propaganda ist,
ukrainische Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht gering,
aber ja, es ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen,
dass das tatsächlich zutreffend ist und insofern, also
es könnte da ein bisschen brutaler
zu gehen als das so den den
anschein hat gerade und auf jeden fall scheinen sie
auch mit ukrainischer oder von ukrainischer artillerie
unterstützt worden zu sein und angeblich auch mit heimars angegriffen worden
zu sein behauptete zumindest dieser wehrpflichtige aber ja vielleicht ist das
auch nur um die angst und und Furcht der Russen zu wecken vor Heimars.
Oh Gott sie kommen mit Heimars.
Ja gut, ich meine Heimars liegt natürlich voll, also meine Ukraine könnte problemlos
und hat es wahrscheinlich auch schon getan in Belgorod mit Heimars Ziele angreifen.
Also das ist ja von der Reichweite her ausreichend. Da ist natürlich wieder
eben diese Frage, wie stehen die Amerikaner dazu?
Weil ja immer so diese Doktrinen draußen ist, so mit den Raketen aber bitte
nicht auf russischem Gebiet angreifen. Von daher glaube ich das jetzt nicht,
dass hier Heimas zum Einsatz kam.
Aber das ist auch nicht unbedingt erforderlich, weil auf diese kurze Distanz
haben die Ukrainer auch ihre eigenen Raketen,
Waffen, Drohnen und so weiter alles, also so super wichtig scheint das dann
doch nicht zu sein, da in Begrud jetzt konkret die Ziele zu vernichten.
Sondern es geht einfach darum, Russland hier in so eine Imbalanz zu bringen,
weil natürlich eine Truppenverlagerung aus den Kampfgebieten auch bedeutet,
dass diese Soldaten sehr große Wege zurücklegen müssen.
Was ich jetzt hier recht an der Stelle ist,
dass Russland keine Grenzen hat und zwar sagen erstmal von sich aus einfach
Unklarheit geschaffen hat,
wo denn jetzt Russlands Außengrenzen eigentlich wirklich verlaufen.
Wieso, wie meinst du das?
Naja, durch die Annexion der Gebiete gibt es jetzt mindestens drei mögliche
russische Außengrenzen.
Das ist sozusagen einmal die offizielle.
Russische also grenze aus aus russischer sicht die halt so Donetsk,
Luhansk und Zaporizhja und Kerkhoff Kershon, so eine Mischung aus Karkiv und Kershon.
Genau, und Krim, ne? Genau, genau.
Ja, plus, genau, dann könnte man noch entweder, ja, Krim noch russisch oder nicht.
Es gibt unglaublich viele Varianten von russischen Grenzen.
Oder nimmt man irgendwie Russia proper, die völkerrechtlich anerkannten Grenzen.
Aber dadurch, dass Russland jetzt selbst seine Außengrenzen so schwammig gemacht
hat, fällt es natürlich leicht, auch dieses Tabu zu brechen.
Weil die Ukraine ja ohnehin aus russischer Sicht russischen Boden schon längst
angreift und sich längst auf russischem Boden befindet.
Insofern ist dann quasi die Originalgrenze jetzt, hat dann auch nicht mehr dieses
Gewicht, dieses absolute Gewicht, wie sie es hätte, wenn die Russen es nicht annektiert hätten.
Plus, das ist natürlich Moskau, das konnte man auch ganz schön sehen,
einfach auch die eigene Bevölkerung in Grenznähe nicht wirklich interessiert,
dass die halt nicht nur bereit waren, dann dort zu bombardieren einfach und
auf eigenem Gebiet auch keine Rücksicht auf
die Bevölkerung oder deren Eigentum zu nehmen, sondern dann ja auch selber russischen
Boden bombardiert haben, mit schweren Waffen als erste.
Bis hin aber, dass auch dann die geschickten Truppen im zweiten Schritt sich
halt auch verhalten haben sollen. Die russische Truppen sich dann nun mal gerne
auch verhalten, wenn sie dann irgendwo hingeschickt werden.
Also Läden geplündert etc.
Ja, nämlich dort auch Läden geplündert haben und die Zivilbevölkerung,
die eigene russische Bevölkerung drangsaliert haben.
Das heißt, die russische Armee scheint da jetzt nicht so den großen Unterschied
zu machen zwischen Russen auf völkerrechtlich russischer Seite und Russen auf
völkerrechtlich ukrainischer Seite.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und dann am Ende, ja, solange es nicht wirklich Moskau betrifft, sind auch.
Die Randprovinzen, ja, das scheint Verfügungsmasse zu sein für die Russen.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es natürlich auch blamabel.
Also nichts tun geht auch nicht. Und die russische Propaganda hat natürlich
auch riesige Schwierigkeiten, jetzt mit diesem Thema umzugehen,
weil eine gute Lösung gibt es einfach nicht.
Das ist halt ein schönes, klassisches Dilemma.
Einerseits, man sagt, naja, die Ukrainer meinen es nicht ernst,
die wollen uns nur provozieren, unsere Truppen von anderen Gebieten abzuziehen
und wir sollten nicht darauf reinfallen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite zu sagen, naja, wir lassen die jetzt mal frei walten und schalten,
führt halt auch nicht gerade zur Begeisterung in der russischen Bevölkerung
oder auf russischer Seite,
sondern da natürlich auch, ja, muss es jetzt irgendwie unterbinden, Aber ja, nur wie?
Also ein wirklich richtig schönes Dilemma, das da geschaffen wurde.
Genau, Dilemma, das ist glaube ich das richtige Stichwort. Das wird ja auch,
wenn man so Militäranalytikern zuhört, bei der Beurteilung der unterschiedlichen
Ereignisse in diesem Krieg immer wieder klar.
Ein ukrainischer Erfolg kann vor allem viel damit zu tun haben,
wo es den ukrainischen Kräften gelingt bei den Russen so ein Dilemmata zu erzeugen.
Also sie sind vor zwei schlechte Optionen zu stellen. Sie können irgendwie das
eine machen und jetzt hier Belgorod verstärken, damit solche Angriffe nicht mehr passieren können.
So, dann schwächen sie sich aber sozusagen im anderen Bereich und wenn sie das nicht tun,
dann haben sie natürlich ein Propagandaproblem im eigenen Land,
beziehungsweise könnte das ja dann auch wirklich zu einem Angriff auf Belgorod
vielleicht führen, der dann auch signifikant wiederum ihre Versorgung der Kriegsgebiete einschränkt.
Ja und dann auch noch Verhandlungsmasse schafft für mögliche Friedensverhandlungen,
die dann irgendwann kommen.
Das ist ja nicht schlecht, wenn man dann sozusagen eigene Gebiete hat.
Ja, aber es ist immer so schön heiß, genau, wenn man für den Gegner ein Problem
schafft, hat der möglicherweise dafür eine Lösung, aber wenn man ein Dilemma
schafft, gibt es eben nur zwei schlechte Alternativen.
Und diese Angriffe um Lehrgebiet Bergeroth fallen genau in diese Kategorie hinein.
Genau, zu deinen Grenzen vielleicht noch die Anmerkung, also die beiden Oblaste,
die beiden ukrainischen Oblaste, von denen aus jetzt diese Angriffe ausgestartet wurden,
die sind natürlich noch nicht von Russland proklamiert worden,
dass es eigenes Staatsgebiet sei, also das ist die Region Rakiv und beim ersten
Angriff ging das aus der Region Sumi heraus, also Oblast Sumi und ja dementsprechend.
Allerdings gehörte die Oblast Belgorod, also hat auch einen ukrainischen Namen,
weil das auch mal zu Ukraine gehört hat.
Also insofern, wenn man da jetzt auch weiter zurück geht, überhaupt gehörte
ganz Russland irgendwann mal zu Ukraine war ja so.
Das machen wir uns nicht auf.
Lass uns mal voranschreiten, jetzt kommen wir zu den weiteren Aktionen,
also was dann erstmal noch parallel passiert ist,
weil passiert ja sozusagen nix unabhängig davon,
Das waren halt verschiedene Shaping-Offensiven,
da kommen wir noch dazu, aber wie schon angedeutet, hat sich halt nun Wagner,
also die Söldnertruppe da von Prigogine, jetzt sozusagen Hände ausgeklatscht
und gesagt so, ja das war's jetzt, wir ziehen uns mal zurück und übergeben jetzt
das eroberte Gebiet an die russische Armee.
Das heißt, die haben dann diese ganzen gewonnenen Stellungen besetzt.
Und schon glaube ich zur letzten Sendung gab es ja auch schon ein paar Gegenangriffe,
also während die Rosen auf dem eiligen Stadtgebiet von Bachmuth nach vorne gegangen
sind, haben die Ukrainer angefangen links und rechts davon die Flanken anzugreifen.
Das ist am Anfang sehr schnell vorangegangen, jetzt ist es so ein bisschen hin
und her. Die Berichte sind generell sehr undetalliert gerade,
weil ja auch grundsätzlich so eine totale Schweigeminute ausgerufen wurde.
Also man versucht sozusagen so wenig wie möglich über die Angriffsoperationen
der Ukrainer zu diskutieren,
einfach um die Operationen nicht zu gefährden, aber es sieht schon so aus,
dass es stellenweise gelungen ist von der russischen Armee um Bachmuth herum
gewisse Stellung wieder zurück zu erobern.
Das hat jetzt noch keinen entscheidenden Fortschritt gemacht,
aber man sieht schon, dass auch hier auch so eine Dilemma-Option da ist,
weil dieses ganze Bachmut, nachdem es jetzt erobert ist, stellt ja wie gesagt
keinen militärischen Wert dar.
Also es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt von Bachmuth aus, wenn man das jetzt kontrolliert,
auf einmal irgendwie so den direkten Durchmarsch zum nächsten Ziel machen könnte,
sondern da hinter Bachmuth, Bachmuth liegt ja selber in so einem Tal,
daneben sind Anhöhen, die sind dann alle ukrainisch besetzt oder zumindest noch
weitgehend und ein Vorstoß darüber hinaus würde also noch mal mindestens denselben Aufwand kosten,
den sie jetzt schon in Bachmuth getätigt haben und das war natürlich eigentlich
viel zu viel und jetzt wo dann eben die Ukrainer ihn auch noch die Flanken streitig
machen und dann theoretisch die Gefahr bestünde,
dass sie vielleicht dort überrannt werden und Bachmuth dann wiederum von außen
eingeschlossen wird und sie diese neun Monate lang erkämpfte Gebiet dann wieder freigeben müssen,
das wäre natürlich die größte Blamage überhaupt in diesem Krieg.
Die ja an Blamagen für die Russen jetzt auch nicht arm ist.
Aber das zeichnet sich jetzt noch nicht ab, dass da entscheidende Fortschritte
erzielt werden, aber es ist jetzt eben auch nicht so, dass die Russen hier in
irgendeiner Form auf dem Vormarsch wären. Das sind sie nämlich,
Spoiler, derzeit nirgendwo.
Also es sieht eher so aus, als ob jetzt das Heft des Handelns wieder zur Ukraine wechselt.
Das hatten wir ja schon mehrfach in diesem Krieg, wie es immer so ein bisschen
hin und her schwingt. Mal ist die eine Kriegspartei tonangebend und bestimmt
wo das geschehen ist, mal ist es die andere.
Und bei den Großoffensiven in...
In Rakiv und natürlich dann auch in Kherson, da war es natürlich ganz klar,
dass da die Ukrainer das Kriegsgeschehen bestimmt haben und die Russen nur noch reagieren konnten.
Beim Kampf um Bachmut war es natürlich jetzt andersrum und das ändert sich jetzt
offensichtlich wieder.
Ja wie sieht es jetzt aus da mit Wagner? Also,
Prygorjin, du hast es ja auch genauer angeschaut, der ist ja auch nicht arm
an Wortmeldungen und ist ja die ganze Zeit nur am rumkabbeln.
A. Also es wird auch immer wieder gerüchtelt,
er wolle sich auch irgendwie für die nächste Präsidentschaftswahl ins Spiel
bringen als Gegenkandidat zu Putin oder als Ersatz,
falls Putin dann nicht mehr lebt bei den nächsten Wahlen, das wird halt gemunkelt
und es hieß ist ja von ihm, er würde sich jetzt seine Aktivitäten auf Afrika konzentrieren.
Das war ja so, dass das das erste Ding, wobei man natürlich auch immer vorsichtig
sein muss. Ich frage mich, okay, wie viel davon ist vielleicht einfach Theater
auch und mit Putin irgendwo abgesprochen?
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch möglich,
weil ganz offensichtlich, Wenn Putin sagen würde,
okay, das war es jetzt, der muss weg, dann könnte Putin natürlich jederzeit
eben komplett den Finanzhahn und den Waffenhahn.
Drehen, ja, aber ganz offensichtlich entweder will Putin das nicht,
oder ist dazu nicht in der Lage,
aber ich glaube dann eher so ein bisschen ersteres und vielleicht nutzt er ihn
auch einfach nach dem Motto teile und herrsche,
um dann wieder anderen Leute wie Schoigu oder Kadiroff oder.
Seine Geheimdienste oder wer auch immer, um die halt alle so untereinander in
Rivalität zu halten und damit eben seine eigene Position auch zu sichern.
So das natürlich auch dahinter stecken.
Aber andererseits ist das, was Prigogine macht,
wirklich so extrem, dass man sich schon wundert,
dass der Mann überhaupt noch lebt oder dass dass Putin sowas toleriert und die
letzte Aktion davon war,
wo er den russischen Oberstleutnant Gennadijewitsch gefangen hat und ihn gefoltert
und verhört hat und ein Video von diesem Verhör veröffentlicht hat.
Ja, ja, also es ist so ein typisches, ich sag mal, Kriegsgefangenen-Video über
eine Minute lang, haben wir hier auch verlinkt.
Und wo Genadowitsch gezwungen wird zu behaupten, er wäre betrunken gewesen und
hätte befohlen auf Wagner-Truppen zu schießen.
A.
Bezieht sich das auf die Vermienung des Rückzugs?
B. Ja, ja, genau. Also Vermienung, das angeblich hätte den Rückzug vermient
und hätte angeblich auf und russische Truppen hätten auf Wagner geschossen und ja.
Und dann hat er ihn aber offensichtlich freigelassen,
weil er hat sich jetzt dann gestern zu Wort gemeldet,
jetzt Gennadowitsch, und hat wiederum,
hat dazu der Gefangenschaft kein Wort verloren,
aber Wagner des Diebstahls, Schanghain und Entführung und Folter russischer
Soldaten bezichtigt und gesagt,
dass Wagner schon, also seit Anfang an, seit die irgendwie nebeneinander da stationiert waren.
Leute bei ihm einfach abgeworben hat oder beziehungsweise gezwungen hat,
bei Wagner zu unterschreiben, ja.
Also quasi einfach Soldaten, was schon in jeder Armee ein Unding wäre,
wenn du einfach hingehst als Söldnertruppe und aktive Truppen im Feld quasi
aus der Armee für dich rekrutierst, so.
Und die zum Teil sogar dazu gezwungen zu haben,
die auch entführt zu haben, russische Soldaten entführt zu haben und die dann
nur gegen Waffen und Gerät wieder rausgegeben zu haben.
Das heißt, dass sich Wagner auf
diese Art und Weise dann auch Munition und Gerät verschafft haben soll,
indem sie das Gewaltsam von der russischen Armee gestohlen oder erpresst haben vor Ort.
Und ja, wie viel davon stimmt, schwer zu sagen, aber das behauptet jedenfalls
dieser russische Oberstleutnant jetzt, dass das sozusagen der Grund war.
Das heißt, im Moment beschuldigen sich Wagner und russisches Militär gegenseitig
der Verbrechen an der eigenen Seite.
Und waschen diese Wäsche, schmutzige Wäsche, in aller Öffentlichkeit.
Und wenn es dann schon zur Sache geht, kann natürlich irgendwie Kadirov auch nicht fehlen.
Da muss ich dir natürlich auch noch die Tschetschenen mit einmischen.
Ja, die Tschetschenen, genau. Die kommen nämlich jetzt auf einmal auch wieder mit eigenen Truppen.
Ein bisschen unklar, was die da bewirken sollen.
Ich meine, es ist ja ohnehin ziemlich absurd, dass dieses gesamte Aufgebot,
was Russland dort in diesem Ukraine-Krieg bisher hingelegt hat,
auch so eine Art Patchwork, Organisationspatchwork ist.
Also es gibt so die normale russische Armee, haben wir ja auch schon vor längerer
Zeit schon mal drüber gesprochen,
Wagner Truppen, dann gibt es ja noch ein oder zwei andere private Söldnergruppen,
die jetzt nicht so im Gespräch sind, ich hab den Namen jetzt gerade vergessen,
also mindestens eine weitere, die auch noch aktiv sind.
Dann gibt es halt schon immer diese merkwürdige Unterordnung da mit der LPR,
DPR, also quasi so aus den besetzten Gebieten in Luhansk und Donetsk gebildeten
Truppen, ja, die im Prinzip,
Auch keiner mehr weiß, woraus die sich jetzt eigentlich noch zusammensetzen
und ob es die eigentlich auch überhaupt noch gibt,
also ich hab auch Berichte gelesen, dass einfach, so schlimm das klingt,
also in Donetsk und Luhansk, dass es einfach auch überhaupt gar keine jungen
Männer mehr gibt, die man dort noch in den Krieg schicken könnte oder zumindest
nicht in Nenzen, also sie haben halt einfach dort schon alle verheizt.
Das ist halt auch wirklich crazy.
Und jetzt auch noch die Tschetschenen, die ja dann sowieso so ein bisschen als
die TikTok-Warrior bekannt sind und eigentlich bisher in diesem Krieg immer
nur so die Rolle gespielt haben, dass wenn irgendwo was eingenommen wurde,
sind die da hingegangen,
haben sich dann in ihren unbeschmutzten, gut ausgestatteten Uniformen dort präsentiert
und irgendwelche TikTok-Videos gemacht.
Also die haben nicht wirklich gekämpft, sondern die waren einfach nur so da
und haben so Show gemacht. Und jetzt sollen sie auf einmal dann doch kämpfen.
Da bin ich mir sehr gespannt, wie es kommt.
BK'IN WERDER. Ja und angeblich sollen sie auch noch bevorzugt als Barriere-Truppen
eingesetzt worden sein,
die verhindern sollten, dass sich russische Truppen zurückziehen und quasi von hinten dann,
also sagen, auf flüchtende Russen, von der Front flüchtende Russen dann schießen
oder die gefangen nehmen.
Wie Wagner das ja auch gemacht hat.
Ja, ja.
Tja.
Also, ja, und jedenfalls gab es dann aber natürlich auch sagen,
ja, Beef jetzt mit den Tschetschenen,
weil Prigozhin behauptete, ja,
als dass die Kadirov-Tschetschenen nicht in der Lage sein würden,
Wagner-Truppen in Bachmuth zu ersetzen, weil sie zu schwach dafür seien.
Da fühlte sich dann die Tschetschenen persönlich auf die Füße getreten.
Und dann irgendwie Delem Tschanow, ein Tschetschenenführer, hat das dann scharf
kritisiert, auch öffentlich.
Dass Wagner, dass Prigozhin behauptet,
sie seien dafür zu schwach und dann entsprechend verbal zurückgehauen.
Daraufhin meldete sich dann ...
Der Wagner-Gründer Dimitri Utkin zu Wort und erinnerte daran,
man kenne sich ja aus dem Ersten und Zweiten Tschetschenien-Krieg, weil Dimitri Utkin,
also so ein Neonazi, wie er im Buche steht oder wie man in Hollywood auch so
einen Neonazi filmen würde,
so mit SS-Runen auf die Schultern tätowiert und so, oder auf die Brust tätowiert und so.
Und ja, der hat eben tatsächlich auch in den beiden Tschetschenien-Kriegen auf
russischer Seite mitgekämpft und deutete dann quasi damit an,
naja, so nach dem Motto, kommt doch, wir haben euch schon zweimal irgendwie
eins auf die Nase gegeben.
Der erste Tschetschenienkrieg nicht so Am Ende so aktueller Stand dieses Theaters ist,
dass Prigozhin behauptet, jetzt in einem Telefonat mit Kadirov jetzt alles geklärt
zu haben und dass sie wieder irgendwie Freunde sind aktuell und konnte dann aber nicht,
ja, hat das dann wieder genutzt,
um dann wieder auf Sergei Shoigu, den russischen Verteidigungsminister und den
Generalstaatschef der Rassimov einzuhauen und hat gesagt,
sie seien schuld am Tod vieler Wagner-Truppen, weil sie zu wenig Munition geliefert
hätten und hat die Schuld an dem Streit mit Kadirov an Moskau gegeben,
dass Moskau Zwitrach zwischen ihm und Kadirov gesät hätte und dann auch noch
angeboten, natürlich in Belgorod auszuhelfen.
So nach dem Motto, naja, wenn wir Probleme an der Grenze haben,
ich könnte die ja lösen. Man hat sich da auch quasi injiziert.
Und wollte da schon auch Kriegsgefangene,
weil tatsächlich diese Truppen, diese Pseudo-russischen Truppen,
die da eingedrungen sind in der Belgorod-Region,
haben auch dann irgendwelche russischen Kriegsgefangenen gemacht und hatten dann erst angeboten,
die zurückzugeben, wenn der Bürgermeister von Belgorod mit ihnen spricht,
der hatte sich dann auch zunächst dazu bereit erklärt, aber dann zurückgerudert,
woraufhin dann eben Prigogine meinte, ja, okay, dann gehe ich eben und hole
die Kriegsgefangenen zurück.
Aber am Ende ist da nichts passiert und die Gefangenen gingen wohl jetzt in
den allgemeinen ukrainischen Kriegsgefangenen Pool und werden dann auf üblichem
Wege jetzt ausgetauscht.
Das ist wohl, das war wohl der Stand der Dinge.
Aber ja, also ein wirklich ein unglaubliches Theater,
was da passiert und wo man sich dann fragt, sind die alle eigentlich so irre
oder ist das zum Teil auch einfach kalkuliertes Theater,
um ja abzulenken von anderen Dingen.
Man weiß es nicht so genau, aber was da teilweise über die Öffentlichkeit dann
gespielt wird, statt hinter verschlossenen Türen, ist schon absurd, finde ich.
Klingt nicht professionell. Nicht wirklich.
So, dann ging es irgendwie los.
Also diese Gegenoffensive der Ukraine wird ja nun schon lange diskutiert.
Vor allem wird sie ja auch schon lange von der Ukraine diskutiert.
Also seit letztem Jahr wird immer wieder geredet von, ja aber im Frühling und
so weiter, dann geht es wirklich richtig los und wir werden uns alles wieder zurückholen.
Es war mir nicht immer klar, wer so die Empfänger dieser Botschaft so sein sollen,
aber ich würde sagen, das ist schon so eine Mischung aus sowohl Botschaft nach
innen, als auch Botschaft nach außen.
Also auf der einen Seite natürlich die Adressaten der ukrainischen Bevölkerung,
so nach dem Motto, Mag gerade ein bisschen scheiße aussehen hier und da,
aber wir werden das schon schaffen und wenn die große Offensive kommt,
so das wird schon alles in Ordnung bringen.
Auf der anderen Seite halt Botschafts an die Russen, so fürchtet euch sehr,
weil selbst wenn ihr meint jetzt hier irgendwelche Gewinne gemacht zu haben,
das ist nur von kurzer Dauer und wir hauen euch richtig.
Und in der Zwischenzeit haben sie natürlich alles dafür politisch mobilisiert,
natürlich vor allem Selenskyj mit seiner Diplomaten-Truppe und hat es ja nun
auch wirklich geschafft in den letzten Monaten,
besonders einfach den Grad an Unterstützung, Man kann sagen eigentlich jetzt
innerhalb eines Jahres komplett zu drehen.
Also von wir geben euch 5000 Helme, vielleicht hilft euch das ja,
zu Deutschland beschließen,
hier ein Milliardenpaket, das ging ja dann relativ schnell und wenn man sich
anschaut was für ein Affentanz noch um diese ganze Panzerlieferung gemacht wurde
und was mittlerweile dann an Gerät zugesagt worden ist,
Das ist halt einfach ganz klar auch ein Sinneswandel den die Ukraine durch ihre
internationale Diplomatie und ihre Strategie wie sie das alles verkündet und
einkleidet getätigt hat.
Also das ist einfach ein großer politischer Erfolg und jetzt muss ich eben auch
zeigen was das dann on the battlefield auch wirklich für eine Auswirkung hat.
Viele Länder drehen ihre Munitionslieferungen hoch und vor allem ihre Produktionen hoch.
Auch hier in deutschland reinmetall und so weiter also alle bauen ihre kapazitäten
aus und das geht ja auch weltweit so es sind es ist mittlerweile eigentlich überhaupt kein,
gerät mehr was ihnen groß versagt wird sogar die f16,
Flugzeuge und damit haben wir glaube ich die letzte Sendung noch beendet,
dass wir gesagt haben, das wird jetzt auch nicht mehr so lange dauern und dann
ist das Thema auch durch, das ging dann wenige Tage später tatsächlich über die Ticker,
dass die Amerikaner ihren Widerstand dort aufgegeben haben und es jetzt so aussieht
als ob Dänemark und Niederlande vor allem größere Kontingente von F-16 Flugzeugen
bereit sind an die Ukraine abzugeben und es gibt auch Berichte das auch schon
Piloten trainiert worden sind etc.
Also will sagen, es ist jetzt einfach gelungen durch diesen politischen Druck
wirklich einen großen Flow an Militärgerät,
Munition, Training und neuen Fähigkeiten, Abwehrsystem, Flugabwehrsystem etc.
Ins land zu bekommen beziehungsweise auf den weg zu bringen und das ist sozusagen
die unterfütterung einer gegen offensive jetzt erstmal nur was so die ausstattung.
Betrifft so allerdings muss man auch ein bisschen genauer hinsehen finde ich
und man kann jetzt tatsächlich.
Dass das Thema auf verschiedene Art und Weise sehen. Auf der einen Seite,
völlig richtig, von 5000 Helmen bis F-16 ist eine ganze Menge passiert.
Und tatsächlich jetzt an grundsätzlich Arten von Waffensystemen scheint da jetzt
nicht mehr viel zu fehlen,
wenn wir jetzt von westlichen Kampfflugzeugen reden und Kampfpanzer,
die ja lange Zeit das große Tabu waren.
Jetzt ist es aber nicht so, dass wir jetzt die Ukraine in beliebigen Mengen
mit modernsten Waffen ausgestattet haben.
Teilweise sind recht moderne Waffen geliefert worden oder tatsächlich aktuelle
Waffen, aber bei den Kampfpanzern ja, einen Teil davon relativ neu.
So, aber eben auch sehr viel einfach älteres Material und wenn man sich die Stückzahlen anguckt,
dann ist da über zwei Drittel tatsächlich alter Kram mit dabei,
der zwar immer noch gut ist und der Ukraine hilft,
aber so ein Leopard 1 Panzer ist teilweise auch natürlich super zu haben,
aber das ist jetzt nicht das Szenario, naja, sie haben jetzt das Tollste und
Feinste gerade von der NATO bekommen.
Ähnliches gilt halt für die F-16.
Die F-16, die sie wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal kriegen, sind jetzt auch nicht
the latest and greatest,
sondern das sind erstens natürlich Generation 4 Kampfflugzeuge,
was natürlich der große Vorteil ist.
Es gibt sehr, sehr viele davon und die sind halt extrem kompatibel mit allen
möglichen anderen Waffensystemen.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Fortschritt so, aber Die Ukraine kriegt jetzt
auf absehbare Zeit zum Beispiel keine F-35 Tarnkappen oder Stealth Flugzeuge beispielsweise.
Was sie auch noch nicht bekommen haben, sind wirklich Langstrecken-
Waffen. Was immer noch ein bisschen unklar ist, jetzt auch mit den mit den Storm Shadows,
sind das jetzt die 250 Kilometer oder die 500 Kilometer plus Varianten,
die sie da bekommen haben beispielsweise,
weil die 250 Kilometer Variante ist halt die Exportversion und das was jetzt England,
Frankreich und Deutschland in ihren Beständen haben, sind aber die Vollversion mit voller Reichweite.
Vielleicht haben sie ja gesagt, naja gut wir liefern euch die Vollversion,
aber ihr dürft die nicht weiter als 250 Kilometer oder so damit angreifen.
Das könnte jetzt auch irgendwie der Deal gewesen sein. Wir wissen es nicht so genau.
Und die Mengen natürlich sind jetzt zwar signifikant, also auch an Munition
und an Panzern und Flugzeugen,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass damit die Ukraine jetzt mehr Panzer oder mehr
Artillerie oder mehr Flugzeuge hätte oder mehr bessere Flugzeuge als Russland.
Das muss man halt auch immer bedenken, dass jetzt mal rein,
was die Technik angeht, gibt es zwar ein paar punktuell super wichtige Waffensysteme,
aber umgekehrt haben die Russen natürlich auch in kleinen Stückzahlen eine Menge
Hightech Waffensysteme und auch das ganze Thema elektronische Kampfführung und Luftabwehr und so.
Da hat Russland ja auch erhebliche Mengen. Plus,
dass sie wohl in der Lage sind, 30 bis 50 Raketen im Monat aktuell auch selber zu produzieren.
Also ballistische Kurzstreckenraketen oder Cruise Missiles, mit denen sie weiterhin
auch versuchen, ukrainische Städte zu bombardieren.
Alles richtig was du sagst, so gar keine Frage. Allerdings muss man das natürlich
auch von dem Hintergrund sehen, was ist denn realistisch auch lieferbar.
Also es wird sozusagen alles geliefert was geliefert werden kann.
Die Verstärkung mit den F-16 Bombern ist halt, also ich meine F-35 ist überhaupt
gar keine Option für die Ukraine, weil die einfach niemals in nennenswerten.
Verfügbar wären, während die F-16 noch verhältnismäßig taugliche,
moderne Flieger sind, die universell eingesetzt werden können und die eben jetzt
gerade bei so Ländern wie Dänemark, Niederland und ein paar anderen auch noch
ohnehin gerade durch F-35 ersetzt werden.
Also das ist sozusagen der normale Cycle, dass sie dann quasi das Gerät,
was ausgemustert wird, dann eben übernehmen, weil das hätte ja sowieso irgendwo
hingehen müssen und von daher ist das halt eigentlich die richtige Lösung.
Was die, sie haben natürlich dann immer noch quasi nicht so viele Flugzeuge wie die Russen,
aber sie haben halt überhaupt erstmal fähiges Material was einerseits vorgesehen ist,
alle modernen NATO Waffensysteme die man auf so Flugzeuge packen kann,
kriegst du an F-16 dran, Teilweise ist es ja schwierig,
bestimmte Waffentypen überhaupt mit so einer Mig 29 und was die Ukraine vielleicht
sonst noch überhaupt verfügbar hat,
also nicht für bestimmte, für Stormschelle und so weiter, da mussten sie spezielle
Adapter bauen und so weiter, das gelingt ihnen zwar auch, aber es ist natürlich
nochmal was ganz anderes,
Wenn du weißt, okay wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie ein Geschwader von F-16 und
da kann man im Prinzip alles ranklinken, was die Technologie derzeit so hergibt.
Das macht natürlich auch nochmal einen riesen Unterschied aus,
weil ich denke, das Ziel ist zu verhindern, dass die Russen in irgendeiner Form
nochmal den Luftraum übernehmen.
A.
Und dieser permanente Beschuss mit den Raketen ist ja sozusagen auch der Versuch,
die Luftabwehrsysteme zu überlasten und die Zahl der Abwehrraketen zu reduzieren,
um vielleicht später bei einer Gegen-Gegenoffensive dann vielleicht wirklich
nochmal eine Lufthoheit zu erzielen.
Und das würde natürlich durch diese F-16 nochmal signifikant reduziert werden.
Wobei man die F-16 vielleicht eher sowas wie den VW Golf unter den Kampfflugzeugen sehen kann.
Ist jetzt nicht so das Superspitzenmodell der Oberklasse,
aber halt das Ding, wo es jede Menge Zubehör und Anbauteile für gibt und einen
riesigen Markt und einen riesigen Gebrauchtmarkt und ja so eines der meistverkauften
Kampfflugzeuge der Welt.
Und well understood. Also das ist einfach solide Militärtechnik,
mit der sie halt auch wirklich was anfangen können.
Bei den Panzern ist es halt ähnlich, ja klar. Also auch die ganzen Panzerlieferungen
werden nicht dazu führen, dass
auf dem Papier auf einmal mehr Panzer auf ukrainischer Seite stehen und,
Nur es ist halt auch klar, dass sie zumindest mit den Leopard 2 Panzern eben
technisch weit voraus sind. Also sie haben halt einfach Panzer,
die sehr viel besser funktionieren.
Die muss man natürlich trotzdem noch vor Drohnenbeschuss und Artillerie sichern,
aber so im direkten Kampfeinsatz,
also ein Panzer, der in voller Fahrt sein Ziel jederzeit im Fadenkreuz behalten
kann, weil er einfach automatisch ausgleicht, ist natürlich was ganz anderes
wert als so ein russischer Panzer, der eigentlich immer stehen muss, wenn er schießen muss.
Und es ist einfach angenehmer mit den Dingern zu fahren und zu kämpfen,
die sind besser gefedert, da ist mehr Platz drin, einfach für die Besatzung,
da lässt es sich besser drin leben, es ist nicht so laut und stinkt nicht so.
Also es ist halt ein bisschen komfortabler.
Mit Komfort an der Frontlinie.
Um diesen Block vielleicht mal auch abzuschließen, ich wollte ja eigentlich
auch nur so ein bisschen die Preloads zu dieser Offensive erklären,
weil jetzt die ganze Zeit in der Debatte war ja, wann geht es denn jetzt los?
Und dieses wann geht es denn jetzt los, hat sowieso zwei Aspekte.
Das erste ist, nicht alles liegt in der Hand der Ukraine.
Also Wetter spielt da eine große Rolle, das muss natürlich entsprechend sein
und auch viele andere Parameter müssen stimmen, die sich ja auch permanent ändern.
Wo wird vielleicht nochmal angegriffen?
Welche anderen Taktiken lassen sich die Russen noch einfallen?
Was gibt es für sonstige Ereignisse? Wir kommen ja nachher noch zur Zerstörung des Staudamts.
Das ist definitiv auch wieder so etwas, was natürlich auf einmal wieder die Situation ändert.
Trotz alledem kann man jetzt glaube ich feststellen, dass die Gegenoffensive
in dem Sinne vermutlich bereits begonnen hat.
Das haben wir ja eigentlich auch schon so geahnt und es tut sich was und die
ganzen Vorbereitungsangriffe sind gestartet worden.
Wir haben diesen Einsatz der Storm Shadow Raketen, die halt die Reichweite jetzt
der ukrainischen Kräfte nochmal deutlich erhöht hat.
Wir haben Angriffe auf Militärkontrollzentren, zum Beispiel in Helnytschensk,
das ist ja dieser Ort nördlich, also ganz im Süden von Kherson,
also kurz vor der Krim, wo sich die zurückgezogen haben, nachdem sie quasi in
die Reichweite von den HIMARS Raketen gelangen sind.
Dann haben sie sich quasi aus Resson nach Süden zurückgezogen.
Da wird also jetzt bombardiert. Es wird auf der Krim bombardiert,
es wird in Berdyansk bombardiert etc.
Und viele dieser Sachen versuchen natürlich wichtige Infrastruktur zu treffen.
Also Militärgerät, Öllager etc.
Eisenbahnzentren, alles mögliche ist dort getarget worden.
Hafeneinrichtungen.
Genau so war es, vielleicht haben sie auch mal auf ein Schiff geschossen,
das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Und was noch mit dazu kommt, durch diese ganzen Operationen,
die jetzt gemacht wurden, insbesondere die Änderung in Bachmuth,
aber dann eben auch die Angriffe auf Belgorod, die wir jetzt ja schon diskutiert
haben, führten dazu, dass es dann Truppenverlagerung gibt.
Und Trumpenverlagerung bedeutet, große Mengen von Soldaten auf Zügen oder in
Lastwagenkonvois fahren in andere Städte, kommen dort an und müssen erstmal irgendwo sein.
Und die Ukraine hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass in diesen ganzen besetzten Gebieten
natürlich auch immer noch.
Ukrainische Informanten sind, die dann der Ukraine mitteilen,
hier dieses Haus, da sind jetzt gerade irgendwie 500 neue Soldaten angekommen,
die sind da gerade alle rein so und dann schicken die halt da eine Stormshadow
hin, die zerstört dieses Haus nachhaltig und Auf einmal ist halt so eine komplette
Truppenkonzentration dort auf einmal zerstört worden.
Das ist natürlich so ein Nebeneffekt dieser ganzen Verlagerung,
dass sich dadurch immer wieder so Verdichtungen von Gerät und Personal ergeben
und wenn die Ukraine halt rechtzeitig davon Kenntnis erhält,
dann können die das eben auch nutzen, um sozusagen die Russen auch direkt im
Hinterland effektiv anzugreifen.
Und das ist so ein Teil, der schon mal auf breiter Fond begonnen hat,
also das beobachtet man jetzt schon seit zwei, drei Wochen und das nimmt eher
an Intensität zu und findet zumindest permanent statt.
Und ja auch gerade so diese Angriffe auf diese Hubs wie Berdjansk,
also Berdjansk ist auch am Asowschen Meer,
so eine Stadt nochmal westlich von Mariupol, wichtiges Verteilungszentrum,
weil dort die Russen halt auch mit Schiffen was anliefern können und durch die
Verfügbarkeit der Stormshadow Raketen ist das jetzt eben auch sozusagen Zielgebiet
geworden und das schafft natürlich für die Russen auch wieder logistischen Stress.
Weil die müssen ja dann auch sehen, okay sind wir jetzt hier überhaupt noch
sicher, wo müssen wir unsere Logistikzentren aufbauen, um die Front überhaupt
noch richtig versorgen zu können.
Nebenbei gibt es auch noch Angriffe mit diesen Wasserdrohnenbooten.
Ich habe das ja am Anfang nicht geglaubt. Es gab ja einen Bericht,
ich glaube die Russen kamen sogar zuerst damit raus und meinten so ja hier unser
Schiff Ivan Kurs wurde angegriffen und zwar kurz vor Istanbul,
also da im südlichen schwarzen Meer.
Ja und dann haben sie so ein Video veröffentlicht, wie so eine auf das große
Schiff zufahrende ukrainische Wasserdrohne,
also so ein selbstfahrendes Sportboot dort zerstört wurde mit den Gewehren,
die sie da auf dem Schiff haben.
Und ich dachte erst so das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass jetzt irgendwie diese
Drohnen so weit fast bis zur Türkei vordringen,
ja also wo starten die dann,
wo nehmen die den Sprit her das ganze schwarze Meer zu durchpflügen um dort
dann ein russisches Schiff anzugreifen, fragt man sich ja schon ob da vielleicht
auch noch sowas aus Bulgarien kommt oder so.
Interessanterweise ist nicht viel darüber geredet worden. Tag später gab es
ein anderes Video wo man gesehen hat,
das war nicht die einzige Wasserdrohne, sondern das sieht so aus als ob das
Schiff dann auch zumindest von einer Drohne,
naja ich weiß nicht ob es getroffen wurde, aber zumindest gab
es wohl eine Explosion ob das dann bedeutet dass dann auch dass diese Drohne
noch mal kurz vor Auftreffen des Schiffs von den Russen zerstört wurde oder
tatsächlich selber explodiert ist weiß ich nicht auf jeden Fall das Schiff scheint
überlebt zu haben und ist später dann auch in den russischen Hafen eingelaufen.
Naja, worauf ich hinaus will ist, diese Shaping Operations und diese sonstigen
begleitenden Drohnenangriffe,
das ist sozusagen etwas, was jetzt schon seit Wochen brummt,
aber man kann jetzt auch sehen, dass die eigentliche Bodenoffensive offensichtlich
auch an Fahrt gewinnt, ihr merkt schon, ich bin ein bisschen zurückhaltend mit
dieser Ankündigung, mit jetzt geht's los,
weil das kann durchaus noch sein, dass es noch länger dauert,
aber man sieht jetzt eben gerade in Saporizia, was ja so der Hauptkandidat ist
für eine Hauptoffensive, sieht man, dass dort jetzt auf breiter Front Angriffe getätigt werden.
Und es ist natürlich jetzt keine, ich sag mal, wird auch nicht so D-Day-Style
nach dem Motto, morgens um 9 Uhr am 6.06.
Oder so startet jetzt die Offensive auf breiter Front oder so.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht zu erwarten, sondern mehr ein Ramp-Up eigentlich,
dass halt nach und nach mehr Aktivität dazu kommt, auch an verschiedenen Fronten,
einfach um auch den Gegner so ein bisschen im Ungewissen zu lassen, denke ich.
Das ist das, was wir eigentlich erwarten können.
Aber ich glaube, man kann auch sagen, auch anhand dieser Pst-Kampagne,
weil da hat ja die Ukraine noch so ein Propaganda-Video gemacht,
wo sie drin gebeten haben, dass man möglichst jetzt nicht berichtet über ukrainische
Truppenbewegungen oder Truppenkonzentrationen im Rahmen jetzt der Offensive.
Insofern gibt es auch gerade eine ganze Menge Fog of War und der Großteil dessen,
was wir im Moment auch an Bewegungen oder Vorgängen an der Front haben.
Andere Informationen stammen dann auch von irgendwelchen russischen Bloggern, die das behaupten.
Das muss man natürlich auch immer mit gewisser Vorsicht genießen muss,
während von ukrainischer Seite gerade doch wenig zu hören war jetzt,
was an anderen Abschnitten der Front passiert.
Die Russen sagen natürlich, sie haben alles abgewehrt und töten jede Menge Ukrainer.
Insofern gerade schwierig zu sagen, was sich konkret an der Front abspielt, außer und,
Was die Ukraine halt gemeldet hat, jetzt am 8.6. waren eben 730 getötete Russen
und irgendwie 18 zerstörte russische Panzer und 16 zerstörte Panzerkampfwagen.
Und das heißt, zumindest ist das ein Anhaltspunkt dafür,
dass gerade größere Kämpfe zwischen sowohl mechanisierten Einheiten als auch
Infanterie gerade stattfinden an verschiedenen Stellen der Front.
Oder es könnte auch sein, dass eben gerade auf jeden Fall russische Panzer und
russische Truppen wieder in höherer Zahl angegriffen werden,
wie auch immer zerstört sind und,
wie viel ukrainische Verluste es aber gibt, ist gerade unmöglich zu sagen.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall kann man davon ausgehen, dass jetzt hier die Ereignisse
sich dann doch sehr verdichten werden in den nächsten Tagen,
also gerade die Angriffe da in...
Auf dieser Saporischia Front also
das ist sozusagen die Strecke zwischen Donetsk auf der einen Seite und da wohl
auch das große Atomkraftwerk ist in der Nähe von Saporischia,
also auch Saporischia der Stadt, südlich der Stadt, Da wo das Nibro-Staubecken ist,
oder demnächst gewesen sein wird, kommen wir gleich zu, auf dieser langen Front,
das ist natürlich das, wo alle damit rechnen, dass dort etwas passiert.
Wenn es den Ukrainern in irgendeiner Form gelingt,
hier einen Keil zwischen Ost und West-Frontverlauf zu treiben und damit sozusagen
die Versorgung auch des Ostens über den Landweg zu unterbrechen,
dann dürfte das dann schon einen erheblichen vorentscheidenden Charakter haben.
Denn das, also würde das gelingen und die Russen versuchen natürlich alles das
zu verhindern, das ist ganz klar, die haben sich da tief eingegraben und man
wird sehen wie es jetzt verläuft, aber gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass es in irgendeiner Form möglich gemacht wird.
Diesen Vorstoß zum Erfolg zu bringen, dann ist halt Russland gleich eigentlich
auf drei Ebenen geliefert.
Also erstmal müssen sie Saporizia, den Ostteil dann komplett aufgeben,
weil der wird dann einfach nicht mehr haltbar sein.
Sie werden sich dann auf die Krim zurückziehen, aber auch die Krim steht dann
doof da, weil in dem Moment, wo die Ukraine wieder bis zum Asowschen Meer vordringen
kann, dann ist natürlich die Cache Brücke auch wirklich,
sind wirklich ihre tage gezählt das kann man nicht anders sagen also wenn die
dann sozusagen mit storm shadow so nah herankommen, dann können die da einfach
attacken fahren das wird diese brücke so nicht überleben.
Und wenn dann halt die krim flöten ist dann ist halt auch dieser krieg weitgehend,
Naja, ich sag mal nicht vorbei, aber zumindest vorentschieden. Egal.
Russland versucht auf jeden Fall alles, dem in irgendeiner Form einen Riegel vorzuschieben.
Ja, und stellt sich dabei an, wie sie es halt bisher immer getan haben,
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste.
Vor zwei Tagen kam halt die Nachricht, dass der Staudamm bei Nowakowka zerstört worden ist.
Wer die Topografie nicht mehr so ganz im Kopf hat, die Ukraine wird ja von Norden
nach Süden von dem großen Dnipro-Fluss zerteilt.
Das beginnt oben bei Kiew, geht dann so leicht südöstlich zur Stadt Dnipro,
Dann südlich runter zur Stadt Saporizia und dort ist halt ein riesiges Rückstaubecken,
wo halt auch dieses Atomkraftwerk liegt, bei Enehor da.
Und das staut sich halt alles bei der kleinen Stadt Nowakarkowka,
das war ja eine dieser beiden Orte, wo man im Süden überhaupt diesen Libro übertreten konnte.
Das andere war die Antonowsky Brücke direkt bei der Stadt Hresson,
die ja dann beim Rückzug der Russen komplett zerstört wurde und vorher schon
von den Ukrainern da zerbröselt wurde, um den Russen diesen Rückzug auch möglichst schwer zu machen.
Aber der Staudamm selber, der hat halt eigentlich bisher überlebt.
Das einzige Ziel, was es damals gab, war halt diese begleitende Brücke.
In der einen Kurve wurde er halt von den Ukrainern mit Heimmaß sehr pointiert,
dort traktiert, um auch dort sozusagen Rückzugs- und Verstärkungsbewegungen einzuschränken.
Das ist ihnen ja am Ende auch gelungen, aber der Damm selber hat halt keinen
Schaden genommen. Jetzt ist dieser Damm gebrochen und die Ukrainer waren relativ
schnell dran und haben gesagt so, die Russen waren es und die Russen haben ihn
irgendwie zum explodieren gebracht.
Lass mich kurz noch ein paar Worte zur Historie von diesem Damm sagen,
die ist nämlich auch durchaus interessant.
Also es gab an der Stelle auch bereits im Zweiten Weltkrieg einen Vorgängerdamm,
der war etwas kleiner und der wurde dann allerdings durch die Rote Armee dann in 1941 gesprengt,
um auch eine Überflutung herbeizuführen, was dann aber am Ende die Wehrmacht
nicht gehindert hat, die Krim einzunehmen.
Im Grunde genommen gab es im letzten Krieg an der Stelle auch schon mal so eine
Dampfsprengung damals durch die Russen oder durch die sowjetischen Truppen durchgeführt. Und dann?
Wurde der Damm erst mal wieder während des Krieges noch repariert.
Aber dann, später so in den 50ern, wurde dort ein neuer größerer Damm,
also der, der jetzt aktuell gesprengt wurde, der Nowak-Karkovka-Damm gebaut,
was aber auch noch mal ein riesiges ökologisches Desaster war,
weil dadurch dann noch mal wesentlich größere Landesteile der Ukraine geflutet
wurden und auch hunderttausende von Menschen noch mal umgesiedelt wurden und
auch schon mal wieder jede Menge Ökologie zerstört wurde.
Also dieser Damm an sich, also die Errichtung dieses Dams an sich war halt,
wird halt gerne als ja eines der Beispiele für die sowjetische dann auch ja
Unterwerfung der Natur unter ja den den sowjetischen Willen quasi gesehen.
Also auch so ein typisches sowjetisches Großprojekt und da hängt daneben auch
ein 300 Megawatt Wasserkraftwerk dran, was halt auch nicht gerade wenig ist.
So ist jetzt kein Mega- oder kein Gigakraftwerk, aber immerhin kommt da auch
eine Menge oder kam da eine Menge Strom auch raus.
Das wäre ich noch als interessante Vorgeschichte des Ganzen und,
und so ein bisschen auch gesagt, dass es kam mir das Vorjetzt mit der Zerstörung des Dams,
wie so eine quasi die Fortsetzung des der Kerson-Offensive,
die ja im letzten November stattgefunden hat, wo die Ukraine ja vormarschiert ist.
Und dann drohten die Russen auch mit der Sprengung des Dams,
beziehungsweise bezichtigten sich dann beide Seiten, den Dams sprengen zu wollen. Der blieb dann.
Aber unter russischer Kontrolle und dann passierte jetzt erst mal ein halbes
Jahr lang nichts und jetzt sind die Ukrainer wieder weiter auf dem Vormarsch
und jetzt wird der Damm auf einmal gesprengt,
so quasi wie, okay, dann machen wir jetzt da unten mal ein bisschen weiter und
dann sieht es jetzt erst mal so aus,
kann man so interpretieren, dass jetzt verbrannte oder in diesem Fall überschwemmte
Erde erstmal hinterlassen wurde an der Stelle.
So kennt man das ja von den Russen oder von der roten Armee.
Ja also mit der Schuldfrage ist es so eine Sache also man muss jetzt ja überhaupt
erstmal rauskriegen was ist denn eigentlich wirklich passiert.
Also die Ukraine war natürlich schnell und hat gesagt so ja die Russen waren
es und die haben den gesprengt weil die haben den vermint und die hatten den
ja auch unter Kontrolle und wir kennen sie ja und lalala.
Auf der anderen Seite gab es bisher auch noch keine wirklich überzeugenden Bilder oder Videos,
die in irgendeiner Form eine Explosion auch gezeigt haben und da ja nun die
Ukrainer auf der anderen Seite des Dams war, kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
vorstellen, dass da nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwie eine Kamera läuft.
Also das kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass die da nicht auf der anderen Seite
einfach permanent eine Kamera auf diesen Damm gerichtet haben.
Und wenn nicht, dann frage ich mich wirklich, was mit denen kaputt ist.
Ich kann mir das irgendwie so richtig nicht vorstellen, dass es da kein Bildmaterial
gibt und wenn es das gibt und eine Explosion stattgefunden hat,
dann müsste diese Explosion ja auch in irgendeiner Form zu sehen sein.
Es gibt ja auch wenig Gründe für die Ukraine, das dann nicht zu veröffentlichen,
wenn sie ihren Punkt machen wollen, dass es die Russen waren.
Ich meine, es gab dann auch das Argument, dass die Sprengsätze halt ziemlich
tief und weit unten waren und man deswegen nix gesehen hat.
Aber grundsätzlich gebe ich dir da recht. Wobei dasselbe dann auch für die russische Seite gilt.
Eigentlich müsste man denken, dass beide Seiten irgendwie Aufnahmen davon haben.
Ja klar, weil die Russen ja behauptet haben, es wäre jetzt ukrainische Arterie.
Ich will damit jetzt auch nicht sagen, ich zweifle das an. Ich sag nur,
ich find's ganz interessant, dass es keinen Beleg gibt. Und es stimmt schon,
es gibt ja jetzt auch verschiedene Thesen, was dort passiert sein könnte.
Also ich will's mal grob aufteilen. so in Szenario eins ist.
Das ganze war nicht wirklich geplant und ein totaler Unfall und die Russen haben
diesen ganzen Staudamm sowieso sich nicht ordentlich drum gekümmert und aufgrund irgendeines Fehlers,
irgendeiner Havarie oder einfach nur der Idee mit naja kann ja sein,
dass die uns jetzt hier über den Dnipro angreifen im Rahmen dieser Offensive.
Wir wollen jetzt mal den Hafenfluten in irgendeiner Form mehr Tore aufgemacht
haben oder versucht haben sozusagen vielleicht durch eine kleine kontrollierte
Explosion nur so einen bestimmten Teil zu killen,
ohne gleich alles zu killen, um einfach den Pegel ansteigen zu lassen.
Wobei sie angeblich aber ja die Fluttore unter Kontrolle hatten und in der Lage
waren den Pegel zu regeln und quasi damals erst mal nach den ersten Sprengungen,
also sie haben ja Teile schon mal gesprengt im November dann,
um zu verhindern, dass die Ukrainer da weiter vorrücken.
Und haben dann Teile der Dampfkrone weggesprengt, damit die Ukrainer nicht rüber können.
Davon gab es ja Bilder von dieser ersten Explosion im November,
die jetzt teilweise auch hervorgekramt wurden, um angeblich die aktuelle Explosion
zu belegen, aber das waren wohl alles Bilder von der letzten Explosion im November,
soweit ich das einordnen konnte.
Aber vielleicht kommen ja noch neue Bilder. Es ist halt immer schwierig,
weil das war mitten in der Nacht und Vegetation und so schwer zu beurteilen
auf den auf den Bildern, wann das gewesen sein könnte. Ja.
Aber grundsätzlich scheint es so, dass die Russen quasi das selber regeln konnten
und es hätte jetzt keinen Grund gegeben,
Teile da zu sprengen, sonst hätten sie einfach nur die Tore weit aufmachen müssen,
wenn sie eine Teilflutung machen wollten, wie sie das damals im November auch
schon erstmal gemacht haben, haben sie ein paar Meter abgelassen.
In der letzten Woche, aber jetzt vor der Zerstörung des Dams,
wurden die Tore wohl komplett zugemacht.
Und der Pegel ist dann nochmal um zwei oder drei Meter angestiegen auf den Rekordpegel,
sodass quasi jetzt auch mit der Zerstörung nochmal die Flut möglichst groß gemacht wurde.
Und das ist eigentlich auch ein starkes Indiz dafür, dass die Russen ihre Finger im Spiel hatten.
Meine weitere Variante ist natürlich noch, aber dafür gibt es auch keinerlei Anhaltspunkte,
Oder es könnte auch irgendwo einfach das Militär entschieden haben oder irgendjemand
in der Befehlskette bis hin runter zu einem betrunkenen Soldaten in der Stellung,
der einfach den falschen Knopf gedrückt hat.
Ja, kann, ist auch alles möglich, aber gibt es halt keinerlei Hinweise.
Oder das Militär gesagt hat, das ist uns jetzt zu heikel und wir sprengen das Ding einfach.
Es kann auch sein, ich meine da treiben ja auch teilweise Minen im Fluss oder so,
haben wir auch gesehen, dass da einfach irgendwie eine Miene gegen,
also eine andere Seemine einfach gegen die Sprengsätze gedriftet ist,
die da installiert waren, ja alles.
Alles Möglichkeiten, aber eigentlich die vernünftigste Annahme ist,
dass Russland einfach den Befehl gegeben hat,
diesen Damm jetzt zu sprengen und möglichst viel Überschwemmung zu verursachen,
um die ukrainische Offensive aus dem Tritt zu bringen, was Unerwartetes zu tun.
Das ist für mich die wahrscheinlichste und plausibelste Variante.
Aber es ist natürlich auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass diese Aktion Teil der
ukrainischen Gegenoffensive war.
Und wenn es das war, hätte das halt auch gewisse Vorteile und hätte nicht nur Vorteile,
sondern wäre durchaus auch ethisch zu rechtfertigen aus meiner Sicht,
auch wenn diese ethische Rechtfertigung nicht jeder so leicht wird nachvollziehen können.
Aber wir werden ja fest davon ausgehen, dass die Russen den Damm vermint haben.
So daran besteht für mich kein Zweifel, weil das wäre sonst Quatsch.
Also wenn die Russen sagen, den Damm nicht zu vermienen, Das halte ich für,
also so dumm sind die Russen dann auch nicht, das nicht zu tun.
Vielleicht haben beide Seiten ihn auch vermint. Es wäre jetzt auch nicht unvernünftig
für die Ukrainer den Damm zu vermienen, falls die Russen dort irgendwas vorhätten.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es es nicht.
A.
Weil es ist auf ihrer Seite.
B. Ja, auf ihrer Seite, genau. Aber dafür gibt es halt keine Zeichen.
Aber wir haben zu wenig Informationen aus erster Hand.
Aber wir können also fest davon ausgehen, die Russen haben den Damm vermint.
Und ich glaube wir können genauso fest davon ausgehen, dass im Falle eines ukrainischen
Erfolgs der Gegenoffensive die Russen den Damm sprengen.
So würde ich sagen, mit hundertprozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Sie können es und sie würden es im Erfolgsfall auch tun.
Das heißt, es gibt für die Ukraine eigentlich keine Möglichkeit,
eine Sprengung des Damms zu verhindern und auch keine mögliche und im Falle
des Erfolgs ist sie quasi sicher.
Das heißt, der Damm ist so oder so verloren.
Weshalb es dann jetzt ein Vorteil wäre, den Zeitpunkt für die Sprengung vielleicht
selber zu wählen, statt ihn den Russen zu überlassen.
Weil natürlich die Seite, die vorher weiß, dass die Flut kommt,
kann natürlich mehr gefährdetes Material abtransportieren.
Und wenn jetzt die Ukraine tatsächlich Urheber wäre, müssten wir noch davon
ausgehen, dass da ein größerer Teil an russischem Material und.
Stellungen auch getroffen wurde, die dann nicht rechtzeitig abtransportiert werden konnte.
Aber wir wissen es nicht so genau. Es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass aus Geheimhaltungsgründen man den vielen Truppen auch gar nicht Bescheid
gesagt hat, was passiert und dass die halt einfach auch geopfert wurden von den Russen.
Ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt mit einer Theorie, die sagt, es hätte ja auch die
Ukraine sein können, nicht so richtig anfreunden. Weil meiner Meinung nach summiert
sich das nicht, abgesehen davon, dass da jetzt 16.000,
Ukrainer in den überfluteten Gebieten unmittelbar betroffen sind und dort halt
die Gebäude zerstört werden.
Wenn man sagt ja aber auf der anderen Seite sind ja die Russen,
ja da sind jetzt zwar gerade die Russen aber für die Ukraine ist das halt auch
Ukraine und das sind halt irgendwie auch Ortschaften die sie letzten Endes retten
wollen und sie werden das alles nicht zerstören,
weil wir jetzt von der ganzen Naturkatastrophe und den langfristigen Folgen die das ganze jetzt hat.
Ja es ist ja auch die Hafenanlagen in Kherson sind ja, weiß nicht inwiefern
sie zerstört worden sind, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall betroffen.
Also da wird, das schränkt sozusagen auch die Möglichkeiten der Ukraine jetzt
kurzfristig und langfristig ohnehin nochmal nennenswert ein.
Ich seh da einfach überhaupt gar keine Motivation, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
sollte das halt rauskommen, dass irgendwie Ukraine dahinter steckt,
bitte dich, ja, also das wäre die Herbeiführung eines Kriegsverbrechens, ne?
Ne, ich würde eher sagen, ne für die Ukraine, ich mein, das ist ein ukrainischer Damm und...
Ne, sorry, aber das wird einfach in der westlichen Öffentlichkeit,
käme das null gut rüber und das weiß die Ukraine auch. Also für sie ist die
Unterstützung des Westens, ist für die Ukraine das wichtigste Asset.
Ja, das ist das, was sie auf gar keinen Fall verlieren dürfen,
weil wenn sie das verlieren, ist alles verloren.
Und dementsprechend werden sie sich da nicht so weit vorstellen.
BK'IN DR. MERKEL Ich glaube halt auch nicht dran. Mein Punkt ist nur,
dass selbst wenn es die Ukraine gewesen wäre, das auch kein gutes Zeichen für Russland wäre.
Also auch das, also egal, es spielt halt keine Rolle und es ist natürlich die
Russen behaupten, es sei die Ukraine gewesen.
Insofern muss man sich natürlich auch damit beschäftigen und zu fragen,
okay, für wen hat es denn jetzt, also hätte es auch Vorteile für die Ukraine?
Und da muss man sagen,
möglicherweise schon, ja,
und es gäbe möglicherweise auch durchaus militärische Motive zumindest für die Ukraine,
beziehungsweise umgekehrt, ergeben sich jetzt halt dadurch auch gewisse militärische
Nachteile für Russland.
Beziehungsweise, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass Russland das war,
dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass Russland nicht glaubt, anders einer ukrainischen
gegen Offensive nicht gewachsen zu sein.
Beziehungsweise ein vorübergehendes Hindernis dort schaffen zu müssen,
weil sie Truppen an anderer Stelle brauchen.
Selbst dieses Szenario, egal ob es die Ukraine oder die Russen gesprengt hat, Das.
Spielt für die militärisch-strategische Bewertung nur eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Sondern Fakt ist, der Damm ist weg, er ist zerstört und es gab Überschwemmungen
auf beiden Seiten und beide Seiten sind jetzt in unterschiedlicher Weise betroffen davon.
Gerade. Und die Ukraine muss sicherlich jetzt gewisse Ressourcen abziehen,
um dort der humanitären Katastrophe zu begegnen.
Das heißt, es ist zu einem gewissen Teil beeinträchtigt ist jetzt die Offensive
der Ukraine und erfordert natürlich jetzt auch Aufmerksamkeit und lenkt halt
ein bisschen vielleicht von der Offensive an anderen Stellen ab,
weil jetzt koordiniert werden muss und es wird Transportkapazität gebraucht,
um die Flüchtlinge aus der Gegend abzutransportieren, aber viel davon gilt natürlich
auch auf der russischen Seite,
wobei wir von den Russen halt wissen, dass sie im Zweifelsfall ihnen die Bevölkerung
egal ist und die halt selber zusehen müssen, wie sie klarkommen.
Auf russisch besetzten Gebiet.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, außer dass sie jetzt Truppen vorübergehend für andere
Zwecke zur Verfügung haben, ist der Vorteil für die Russen nicht sehr groß.
Es sei denn, sie haben ohnehin schon beschlossen oder gehen davon aus,
dass die Gebiete eh nicht zu halten sind und sie es dann möglichst teuer für
die Ukraine machen wollen,
wenn die Ukraine dann die Gebiete tatsächlich wieder befreit,
dass dann dort zumindest wenigstens nicht wächst, weil alles vertrocknet ist und ja,
und möglichst viel zerstört wurde und das quasi für die Ukraine einfach das Ganze teurer zu machen.
Umgekehrt könnte man natürlich sagen, könnte quasi auch die Ukrainen ein Interesse daran haben,
eine weitere Besatzung der Gebiete für die Russen so unattraktiv wie möglich zu machen,
indem sie eben genauso auch erst mal dafür sorgen, dass dort nichts geerntet werden kann.
Also diesen hypothetischen Diesen Standpunkt könnte man auch sehen.
Oder faktisch, egal wer es zerstört hat, ist es jetzt für die Russen unattraktiver
geworden, diese Gebiete weiter besetzt zu halten.
Ja, das kann man glaube ich so oder so konstatieren.
Naja, also ich denke die Russen haben bisher noch nicht unbedingt gezeigt,
dass so Zerstörung von Land für sie in irgendeiner Form ein Problem ist.
Die nehmen sich erstmal das Territorium und wenn es irgendwie 50 Jahre dauert
bis das alles wieder zu bewirtschaften ist, dann nehmen sie es trotzdem.
Also die sind ja da sehr rigide und haben ja auch sowohl Infrastruktur als auch
Natur schon auf breiter Front im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zerstört.
Also von daher kann ich das so als Motivation kaum gelten lassen.
Aber das sind ja jetzt auch nur so Gedankenspiele, denen du dich so hingibst,
um sozusagen mal alles abzutasten, was jetzt eigentlich da hinterstecken könnte
oder was man so logisch ausschließen kann.
Ich denke, so wie sich das jetzt gerade präsentiert, kann man schon davon ausgehen,
dass das zumindest ein, also mindestens ein Fehler oder vielleicht ein Vorsatz der Russen war.
Vielleicht haben sie was ganz
anderes beabsichtigt, vielleicht ist ihnen sozusagen die Sache entglitten,
also die haben eine kleinere Maßnahme geplant und man hat das ja auch gesehen,
die Militärblogger, Diese ganze schreiende Meute da auf Twitter und Co,
als es bekannt wurde,
dass der Damm gebrochen war, alle so ja, haben sich dann erst mal lustig gemacht
über ertrinkende Ukrainer und als dann aber sozusagen die Dimension des Ganzen
klar wurde, sind sie alle schnell auf ne die Ukraine war's umgeschaltet.
Und für mich zeigt das so ein bisschen, dass das...
Nicht generell positiv beurteilt wird, bzw. schon gesehen wird,
wie negativ konnotiert dieser ganze Vorgang ist.
Ja, also für mich ganz klar,
das kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug betonen, ist ganz unabhängig davon,
was jetzt zur Zerstörung des Dams konkret am Ende geführt hat,
ohne Putins Invasion stünde der Dam noch.
Ja, kann man glaube ich ganz klar feststellen so und der Damm war auch unter russischer Kontrolle,
wurde von beiden Seiten auch angegriffen, aber wurde auch von Russland zum Gegenstand
von Kampfhandlungen gemacht und wurde von Russland vermint.
Aber insofern, egal wie es am Ende passiert ist,
ohne den russischen illegalen Angriffskrieg stünde der Damm noch,
deswegen ist Putin verantwortlich.
Man braucht eigentlich gar nicht jetzt unbedingt die Details jetzt überhaupt zu debattieren,
Ich fürchte, wir werden auch hier am Ende vielleicht niemals wissen, wie es gewesen ist.
Wenn man sich allein nur anguckt, auch in Syrien teilweise oder an anderen Stellen,
was passiert ist in der Vergangenheit, wo es so unterschiedliche Versionen gibt von den Vorgängen.
Das wird also ganz, ganz schwierig werden, glaube ich, das auch aufzuklären.
Und selbst wenn das dann vielleicht Historiker aufklären, wird es einen großen
Teil von Leuten geben, denen das sowieso egal ist, die ihre festgefügte Meinung
davon haben. Ich denke...
Ganz, ja eher vernünftig, plausibel gedacht, spricht, weist alles auf die Russen hin.
Aber es ist, das Interessante ist, es ist dieselbe Debatte,
wie wir es auch bei, weiß Nord Stream 2 hatten oder beim Angriff auf die Kerchbrücke
oder bei anderen Dingen,
wo sich keine Seite eindeutig zu bekannt hat, dass dann beide Seiten immer mit
dem Finger auf sich zeigen.
In dem Fall spricht fast alles für Russland.
Aber man muss sich trotzdem die Frage stellen, warum, wie bekloppt ist denn
die Idee eigentlich generell?
Und so am Ende des Tages, ja, Folge von Putins Krieg,
mit, würde ich sagen,
mit jetzt kurzfristigen Vorteilen erst mal für Russland,
aber mittelfristig Vorteile für die Ukraine, langfristig Nachteile für die Ukraine.
So könnte man das vielleicht zusammenfassen.
Und da Russland sowieso nur in vielen Fällen sehr kurzfristig zu denken und
zu planen scheint, dann denke ich, hat Russland den kurzfristigen Vorteil jetzt genommen.
Naja, schauen wir mal was es gibt. Man muss auf jeden Fall mal festhalten was
jetzt eigentlich die Folgen davon sind, weil die Folgen sind natürlich signifikant.
Zunächst einmal lässt sich festhalten, der Damm und das Kraftwerk vor allem
sind komplett zerstört, da lässt sich also überhaupt nichts wieder in Betrieb
nehmen oder reparieren oder so, also das ist einfach final.
Ja also nicht nur weil vermutlich schon durch eine Sprengung oder also schon
initial die ganzen Turbinen und so weiter zerstört wurden, es ist halt einfach
das Wasser hat mittlerweile einfach alles abgeräumt was dort an Nennenswetterinfrastruktur stand.
Dann ist das gesamte Hinterland überschwemmt und das ist natürlich wirklich bitter,
weil das sind Naturparks, das ist halt auch Flora und Fauna,
was da also an Wildtieren und wahrscheinlich auch an Nutztieren,
Haustieren, getötet wurde, lässt sich überhaupt nicht beziffern.
Du schreibst hier 50.000 Flüchtlinge. Auf beiden Seiten zusammengenommen.
Achso ja genau, also ganze Nowaka, Kowka selber, die Stadt ist komplett überflutet.
Das ist krass, dann müssen natürlich jetzt auch nochmal eine riesige Katastrophenhilfe
dort eingeleitet werden in der Region.
Das kostet natürlich Geld, das kostet natürlich auch nochmal Koordination,
Konzentration, also ich meine angenommen es wäre jetzt kein Krieg und nur dieser
Staudamm wäre gebrochen,
dann wäre das einfach eine der größten Katastrophen seit Tschernobyl für die Ukraine so.
Und teuer und was nicht alles. Aber nebenbei haben sie halt auch noch seit einem Jahr Krieg.
Und das muss halt jetzt hier alles noch mit zusätzlich gemacht werden.
Alles was sie sich jetzt aber auch militärisch an Brückenköpfen etc.
Aufgebaut haben in den letzten Monaten ist natürlich weg. Das gilt natürlich
dann auch genauso für die Russen. Also die haben dann auch zahlreiche Trenches
und so weiter. Das ist halt alles jetzt nicht mehr benutzbar und es ist auch
noch nicht so ganz klar wie weit sie sich jetzt zurückziehen müssen.
Wobei die Ukraine eben auch auf den Nepro-Inseln sich vorgearbeitet hat.
Die Stellungen sind natürlich jetzt erstmal weitgehend weg oder verloren.
Ja, andererseits, also es hat vielleicht auch was Gutes. Es kann natürlich auch
sein, dass die Artillerie, die russische Artillerie, sich jetzt so weit zurückziehen
müssen, dass jetzt weitere Angriffe auf Rasson, die es ja auch immer wieder
gab, so jetzt erstmal nicht denkbar sind.
Bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, da habe ich jetzt die Auswirkungen der Überflutung
noch nicht so richtig verstanden.
Ja so und mittelfristig ist es natürlich eine totale ökologische und ökonomische Katastrophe.
Zahlreiche Biotope, Naturparks die dort sind, das dürft ihr jetzt alles mit,
Ölverschmutzung alles mögliche gebrochene Industrieanlagen Ausleitungen et cetera
also es dürfte sich wahrscheinlich einfach alles komplett verseucht sein.
Teilweise gab es sogar auch in der Region gab es auch noch verschiedene,
Friedhöfe von, Von verseuchten Nutztieren sowas, was wohl auch wieder alles wieder austreten kann.
Klar die ganzen Ernteausfälle und natürlich auch der Verlust des Kraftwerks,
das ist natürlich alles massiv.
Und man kann festhalten, dass die Gebiete halt erstmal zu einer ökonomischen
Last für jeden werden, der sie in Zukunft jetzt besetzt und verwaltet.
Und wenn die weiter in russischer Hand bleiben,
wird das halt teurer für die Russen und wenn die Ukraine,
wie wir hoffen, sie dann wieder zurück erhält und befreit, wird es erstmal natürlich
eine Last für die Ukraine auch werden.
Und es ist auch nicht nur dieser eine Kanal jetzt,
das hatten wir noch gar nicht angesprochen, dass natürlich dadurch,
dass jetzt der Wasserspiegel dann
auch so fällt in den Becken ist auch einerseits dieser zentrale Kanal,
der die Krim auch mit viel Wasser versorgt, fällt wieder trocken,
sondern es gibt eben grundsätzlich im Süden jetzt der von Kersson und Saporisia
Oblast auch ein riesiges Bewässerungsnetz,
was eben auch dort von diesem Nepro-Speicher aus versorgt wird Und das fällt
natürlich dann jetzt auch erst mal auf Jahre trocken.
Das heißt, da haben wir schon riesige Gebiete, wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung,
vielleicht nicht größenmäßig verglichen, aber wahrscheinlich so von der Größe
Niederniederlande oder so, die da jetzt erst mal dann trocken fallen und wahrscheinlich
massive Ernteausfälle haben.
Werden.
Auf der Krim?
Nicht nur auf der Krim, sondern auch in der Kershawn-Saperija-Oblast.
Wie gesagt, da ist ein riesiges Kanalsystem von Dutzenden von Kanälen,
auch zur Bewässerung, das jetzt auch trocken fällt.
Plus, das Kernkraftwerk hatten wir jetzt nur kurz erwähnt, am Anfang,
wobei ich das eher weniger kritisch sehe, weil das ist jetzt seit einem Jahr aus.
Und das sieht jetzt nicht so aus, als wenn es kurzfristig Probleme geben würde
im Zusammenhang jetzt mit der Dammsprengung,
sondern da hätte man jetzt Monate im Moment Zeit, um eine Lösung zu finden,
um was weiß ich, die Leitung oder die Pumpen ein paar Meter zu verlängern oder
so, um da für Kühlung zu sorgen.
Allerdings ist natürlich das Problem,
dass die Russen weiterhin dieses
Kernkraftwerk besetzt halten und wenn sie nicht einfach bereit sind,
einen Damm zu sprengen, könnte man auch nicht ausschließen, dass sie als weitere
Eskalation oder Androhung einfach dieses größte Kernkraftwerk Europas in Brand setzen könnten.
Das droht noch so ein bisschen quasi als halber Schritt,
bevor sie dann taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen, könnten sie halt dieses Kernkraftwerk
noch in Brand stecken, aber ja, droht jetzt nicht unmittelbar. So.
Dann würde ich sagen, können wir noch einen Ausblick wagen vielleicht,
was jetzt noch so ansteht, was jetzt passieren könnte.
Also es lässt sich festhalten, wir treten jetzt in eine neue Phase.
Davon hatten wir bisher so drei, vier, fünf.
Aber jetzt ist auf jeden Fall eine neue Phase angebrochen.
Unter welchen Titeln, die letzten Endes stehen, wird das glaube ich noch nicht so ganz klar.
BK'IN WIRKLICHEN Naja, es ist jetzt die neue ukrainische Gegenoffensive oder
die Frühjahrsoffensive,
die jetzt im Sommer oder die Sommeroffensive wahrscheinlich wird das dann genannt
werden, die ukrainische 23. Sommeroffensive.
A. Davon gehen wir jetzt aus, aber wissen tun wir das erst danach.
BK'IN WIRKLICHEN Ich meine, die Erwartungen an die Ukraine sind jetzt hoch.
Teilweise hat die Ukraine natürlich selber selbst geweckt,
indem sie auch viel kommuniziert haben und es viel debattiert wurde,
auch im Zusammenhang mit den Waffenlieferungen und Und deswegen,
ja, die Welt, der Westen, aber auch im eigenen Land sind jetzt die Erwartungen,
aber auch bei den Russen, dass jetzt die Ukraine letztlich einen Durchbruch
ans Asowsche Meer irgendwie hinbekommt.
Das ist sozusagen gerade das Ziel der aktuellen Offensive.
Und wenn ihnen das gelingt, dann werden alle einhellig von einem Erfolg reden.
Wenn sie nur, ich sag mal, die Hälfte schaffen, so, wird man wahrscheinlich
davon reden, dass es eher enttäuschend war, ja.
Das, denke ich, wenn man ehrlich ist, so sind wahrscheinlich die Erwartungen,
obwohl man nach wie vor sagen muss,
das ist ein Wunder, ich meine, die Ukraine ist nach wie vor eigentlich David
und Russland ist eigentlich Goliath, aber nach zwei Jahren Krieg haben sich
halt die Erwartungen geändert.
Allerdings sind natürlich Offensiven teuer und blutig und die Russen können
ja ein Lied davon singen.
Die Ukrainer werden sich wahrscheinlich nicht in so etwas reinziehen lassen,
wie die Russen in Bachmut, nämlich monatelange Häuserkämpfe.
Aber ja, sie sind jetzt in der Rolle des Angreifers.
Und es gibt ja immer so die Faustregel, dass eigentlich der Angreifer lieber
mindestens dreimal oder besser zehnmal so viel Kräfte haben sollte,
um schwere Verluste auf seiner Seite zu vermeiden.
Und wenn du aber jetzt, das heißt verteidigen kannst du eigentlich auch in Unterzahl.
Und die Ukrainer kommen jetzt aus einer Rolle, wo sie einen 3 zu 1 Defensivvorteil
genossen haben, in die Situation, dass sie jetzt einen 3 zu
1 Offensivvorteil brauchen, d.h.
Sie müssen irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle ihre Kräfte verzehnfachen gegenüber vorher.
Und das kannst du natürlich entweder, indem du zehnmal so viele Soldaten irgendwo hinpackst.
Aber die Ukraine hat halt nicht im Moment zehnmal so viele Soldaten unter Waffen,
sondern vielleicht doppelt so viele, würde ich größenordnungsmäßig sagen.
Aber diese doppelt so viele Soldaten verteilen sich natürlich auch über die
gesamte Front und müssen natürlich auch die gesamte Front absichern.
So und das heißt um jetzt die nötige, also numerisch werden sie diese...
Quantitativ werden sie diese Überlegenheit nicht hinbekommen,
deswegen man hofft darauf, dass jetzt noch sie qualitativ die notwendigen Vorteile
oder Kampfkraftverstärker bekommen.
Einmal durch bessere Aufklärung, durch bessere Ausbildung und durch bessere Waffen.
Das Thema bessere Waffen hatten wir vorher schon, das ist nur so punktuell gegeben.
Aber ja, was jetzt dann bessere Ausbildung angeht und dann vor allen Dingen
auch besseres Zusammenspiel der Kräfte, Das muss sich halt jetzt zeigen.
Das werden wir jetzt sehen, ob sie es,
darüber wirklich schaffen, auf die notwendige Überlegenheit zu kommen und plus die Moral natürlich,
deutlich bessere Kampfmoral auf Seiten der Ukrainer Und all das zusammengenommen,
müssen sie da auf einen Faktor von 10 kommen.
Und das ist jetzt nicht unrealistisch, aber es ist natürlich auch ein Riesenschritt.
Also eine Riesenumstellung von der Defensive in die Offensive zu gehen,
wie das die Ukraine jetzt gemacht hat.
Ja, also die Situation ist glaube ich nicht hoffnungslos für die Ukraine.
Aber auch nicht einfach. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir einem sicheren Sieg
entgegen blicken, auf der einen Seite, aber es ist auch auf gar keinen Fall
gesagt, dass die Russen da auf jeden Fall gegenhalten können. Das ist total offen.
Aber wenn man jetzt gerade eine Mannschaft wählen sollte, auf deren Seite man sein möchte,
gut ganz abgesehen von den ganzen ethischen Belangen,
wo man lieber auf Seiten der Ukraine sein möchte,
ist aber rein jetzt, wie läuft der Krieg, möchte man glaube ich auch eher auf
ukrainischer Seite sein.
So man kann glaube ich zusammenfassen, dass es für die Russen bislang keine
guten Nachrichten gibt. Die Situation ist nicht gut.
Man kann sagen, okay, sie haben jetzt die Front noch gehalten, so die Front hält.
Und sie haben halt Bachmuth erobert.
Das war es vielleicht mit den guten Nachrichten.
Aber ansonsten, Motivation ist schlecht.
Die Überschwemmungen jetzt in Kasson sind nicht gut für die Russen einfach.
Der Stand der russischen Wirtschaft und Rüstungsproduktion sieht nicht großartig aus.
Der Stand der russischen Reserven, also wie man es dreht oder wendet,
die Zahl der russischen Verluste.
Ich glaube, es macht gerade keinen Spaß, den russischen Truppen die Daumen zu drücken.
Und man merkt es auch an der russischen Propaganda, wie die gerade wirklich
ins Schwimmen kommen, wie die
wirklich nicht wissen, wie sie die ganzen Sachen jetzt bewerten sollen.
Allein auch dieses Vordringen auf russischen Boden von Provokateuren und jetzt dieser Dammbruch,
da kriegst du einfach keinen positiven Spin drauf als russische Propaganda.
Und schwierig werden auf jeden Fall.
Ich denke an der Stelle können wir es jetzt auch abschließen erstmal für dieses
Update. Ich habe so den Eindruck, wir werden jetzt in der nächsten Zeit nochmal
häufiger zusammenkommen müssen, um dem Geschehen noch weiter gerecht zu werden.
Aber das lässt sich natürlich alles nicht so richtig vorhersagen.
Was wahrscheinlich jetzt schwer vorherzusagen, aber was wir weiter jetzt sehen werden,
sind erstmal heftige Kämpfe und ich würde auch nicht völlig ausschließen,
dass jetzt diese Damm-Sprengung auch dazu führen könnte,
dass die Russen sich jetzt sagen, also bevor das ganze,
wenn das ganze jetzt wieder austrocknet, lasst uns lieber auf die Krim zurückziehen,
bevor da oben der Boden wieder trocken ist.
Noch haben wir eine ganz gute Gelegenheit jetzt da weg zu kommen und eine neue Front aufzubauen.
Bauen. So würde ich jetzt nicht völlig ausschließen.
Aber ja, wahrscheinlich werden wir jetzt erstmal an verschiedenen Frontabschnitten
massive Kämpfe sehen in den nächsten Tagen.
Und ob wir dann größere Verschiebungen an der Front sehen.
Schauen wir mal. Ja, hoffen wir es.
Dass dem dem so kommen wird.
Und ja, und auf jeden Fall geht dieser tragische Konflikt weiter mit massiven
Verlusten und wahrscheinlich jetzt auf beiden Seiten aktuell,
auch wenn wir von den ukrainischen Verlusten nicht viel mitbekommen.
Definitiv kann man davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich jeden Tag so im Moment
tausend Menschen in der Ukraine gewaltsam ihr Leben verlieren,
auf beiden Seiten zusammen.
Gut Pavel jetzt machen wir Schluss hier, das war es hier mit unserem Update
wie gesagt wahrscheinlich recht bald schon wieder mehr Informationen und Interpretationen
und Einschätzungen von uns,
aber für heute war es das erstmal, danke fürs zuhören und sagen tschüss bis bald.
Ja, tschüss, macht's gut.